Let's talk about how we might implement the shortestdistnode function.
We give it all the distances we've calculated so far for all the nodes that we could do that for
and so that's just a big pile here.
There is a bunch of nodes and for each node, we have some value
and a lot of these values are temporarily assigned and they may actually change later,
but what we want to know is which of these we'd like to pull out the smallest value
and then we'd actually like to lead it from this set
so we don't have to worry about getting the same value over and over and over again
The next time we want to go in here we want to get the next smallest.
How many different values might be in this blob?
Well, there can be at most one for each node then probably less.
There is probably lots of nodes that haven't been added in yet,
but at worst, it's going to be θ(n).
The nodes that are in the graph may have distances associated with them.
To get the smallest distance in here, the nature thing to do is to loop through the list.
Take all the distances that we actually have at the moment
just loop through them and pull out the minimum, easy θ(n)
and in fact, that's what I implemented here.
The shortestdistnode, you give it a mapping distances
and it starts off with the best node undefined and best value something big
from probably really want something bigger than this and for all the nodes that we have distances for
If the distance for that node is better than the best we've seen so far, reassign
and when you're done, just return the best node.
This is really quite straightforward and what is the running time that this leads to?
These are some tricky run times than the ones I've suggested in the past.
We've got n nodes and m edges, and we want to know,
if we implement the dijkstra algorithm with looping through the list to find the smallest value.
What is the running time that we get? Just make the selection.